[Music]
what was it like growing up in the
Midwest in the 70s
I think it was probably more like
growing up in Hawaii or Washington State
or Florida in the 70s than it was like
growing up in the Midwest and other
decades I think if it was mostly the 70s
and those were the same everywhere
maybe we took it a little bit less
ironically all of that kind of personal
growth and self-realization stuff of the
70s we really bought it again maybe just
for a critical year or 18 months longer
but that's enough to kind of set the
hook I think it's about a prolongation
of innocence and it's a prolongation of
childhood that's that's how I would
describe the Midwest you are just so far
from a border or a coast that the
possibility of cynicism takes just a
little longer when it hits it hits full
force because you have to embrace that
cynicism and that irony in that rage
because you've been duped because you
have survived to a greater age with your
innocence and that is and you feel so
betrayed by the world then that the
first reaction is to become unbelievably
cynical and hard but there is that kind
of soft caramel Center that never goes
away maybe that's just I'm just
generalizing for myself but I know that
I was an unbelievably innocent 18 year
old in every way but not stupid and not
unaware of the world but just in some I
somehow still thought it was a nice
world
year at college basically I went to
Philadelphia oh it was not
Philadelphia's fault I love Philly and
it wasn't those other kids fault they
had come from somewhat tougher East
Coast schools a lot of private school
kids I mean wow the voltage between
their jaded miss and my innocence was
bound to make one of us unhappy and it
wasn't going to be them in some respects
it's never really been ruined there's
something about this whole narrative
that makes me uncomfortable because I
really don't truly don't believe in the
Midwest earnest of the Midwest I cannot
get outside it and account for it I
believe it exists but it's sort of like
the center of the earth you know I don't
actually know for sure that we have a
molten core I just I'm told we do and
there's no reason to doubt it and
they've been there been there must be
there
and the Midwest Midwest which is kind of
the molten core of the country that must
exist to
whenever anyone asks me to generalize
about the Midwest I come want to come
back and say there is no such thing as
the Midwest and every once in a while
someone says you know there's no such
thing as the Midwest and then I want to
argue with that person and say that
that's not true have you ever watched a
Midwestern or get on the subway in New
York City
it was certainly true in my high school
that fashions got there a year or two
later than they did on the coast what we
thought was very very cutting-edge had
was already passe in California and New
Jersey as I bitterly discovered when I
went east to go to college so what that
time-lag represents I'm not sure I just
Midwestern values Midwestern values I
don't think there is such a thing as
been Western values I mean it's kind of
the crank capital of North America right
now the those wonderful Midwestern
Plains states so it's not like what do
you say it's no different from anywhere
else and yet we all feel that there is
something there
you
[Music]